and we were there during that time where
everything just
exploded and i remember launching the
paypal app we went from
uh the first year we had five billion
dollar go through the app
second year 10 billion third year 25
billion fourth year
50 billion it was just growing like
crazy
without us doing too much welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media
partnership with c-tech i am incredibly
excited and
honored to welcome matanbar to 20-minute
leaders
fentech runs in his dna payments
peer-to-peer payments small businesses
groups
individuals name it he's worked on it
welcome tanbar co-founder and ceo of
melio an accounts payable and receivable
solution designed for small us
businesses
before founding melio matano led
paypal's consumer peer-to-peer payments
group globally
responsible for over 50 billion dollars
in payment volume annually
matan joined paypal through an
acquisition of his first payments
company the gifts project
that he co-founded back in 2009 and got
acquired by ebay
inc in 2012. welcome to 20 minute
leaders
how are you
i'm great thanks so much for having me
no no the the honor here is is a hundred
percent mind i can't imagine how
incredibly busy you must be
the ceo of melio but but your journey
which which we'll touch on i'm sure is
no less interesting than
what you're working on today your your
entrance to
the payments and fintech and small
businesses ecosystem all the way from
the gifts project
with guru selling to ebay general
manager at ebay to paypal
leading global teams and now to uh to
melio i think it's just
uh unbelievable and so i'm excited to
both talk about you and
the whole ecosystem of of small
businesses and payments in general
but we will start with soccer because
that is a really good fun fact
how do you become a professional soccer
player in haifa and then transition
yourself
to small business payments world
that thanks for all the the kind words
and uh yeah that's a great question well
in haifa i guess um i think many people
play soccer and uh i think um um
being in the um leading team for your
school
um gets you uh you know
um all the the great benefits of
traveling when you're in school and just
uh
doing something that you love and at the
time i think soccer was ninety percent
of my life really uh
so that and i read every second of it i
think
uh at some point i realized that i'm
better at uh math than uh soccer
so uh i started like decreasing the time
i'm spending on soccer and increasing
the time and spending on
programming and computers uh but
definitely continue to do both and until
today
and we'll continue to do that for many
more years i love that so
your tell me a little bit about the
gifts project is one of you know the
stories that i
that i grew up with when i just entered
thinking about high tech high
everybody was talking about the gift
project and and and following that the
acquisition
to ebay and your entrance there how how
did how did that all begin
where did all this come from
yeah so like any like any good story it
starts with uh
just really great partners uh ron
gura and i know each other from haifa
both of us live in tel aviv today but we
know each other since the age of eight
and as dieckmann uh that was the cto
co-founder and cto
he studied with me computer science uh
in tel aviv university
and maya he's also ron's brother's wife
so we knew each other like we knew each
other for a long long while
and then you know we just thought it
would be really fun to do something
together
i was at my last semester in tel aviv
university
and we started thinking about different
concepts
uh group payments and group gifts was uh
was the concept that the gifts project
was actually based on
and uh we just went for it uh i think we
uh similarly to the story uh or how i
started emilio my my current company
it starts with just making sure that you
want to spend a lot of time with great
partners where you share values with
and going to enjoy working with
regardless of
the specific concept or specific space
in industry
right and so you're you're going with
with the gifts project and you're
talking about
we're starting to talk about the the
fintech ecosystem you're also then ebay
and with with paypal and tell me a
little bit now higher level even before
we go into emilio small businesses
payments peer-to-peer payments what is
this all about
why is this such a complicated ecosystem
yeah yeah that's a great question
because you know i
i somehow been working in fintech for
the past
um i think 14 years uh
um accidentally but i feel very lucky uh
because
i started with the gift project which
was a group payments uh
company and then with ebay and paypal of
course
they got really hardcore in terms of
fintech and financial services
and i i i feel lucky for for two reasons
one
is um fintech
is an incredible space that makes a huge
impact on consumers and businesses
because um it might sound simplistic
but people care about money a lot
like money is very important to people
and when you make money better
uh faster more efficient cheaper
whatever more accessible creating
financial inclusion like
i'll we'll talk about i'll mention a few
examples for
for each of these uh but but
in high level making money better makes
people's lives better
um i think when when looking at the past
year with kovid
of course the health situation was the
number one concern for
everyone around the world but the second
one was you know the
the business and the economy that was
really hit hard and then financial
services
really took a significant role
in the recovery from this terrible
pandemic
and so fintech even became more
important than ever before during that
past year
but money is very important and enabling
uh experiences like the one that i that
my team and i built at paypal for
example
so my team and i at paypal we led um
everything related to friends and family
payments worldwide
so paying back for coffee using the
paypal app
or sending money to my family abroad in
mexico
whatever use case it would be we built
products that enabled
these payments and so for example one of
the products that we've built was the
paypal app
which by the way 80 was built in tel
aviv
um in terms of the the code and product
and design
um and and we launched it in 200
countries
enabling people to move money across the
world
and luckily for us like we were also at
the right time in the right place as
consumers around the world were shifting
from
cash to mobile payments regardless of
our efforts we did a great
job seizing the opportunity i guess but
this was bigger than us consumers around
the world were shifting from
cash and paper checks to uh mobile
payments and now
you know paying with venmo or paying
paying with the paypal app to a friend
became a standard
and we were there during that time where
everything just
exploded and i remember launching the
paypal app we went from
uh the first year we had 5 billion go
through the app
second year 10 billion third year 25
billion fourth year
50 billion it was just growing like
crazy
without us doing too much to be honest
because of this crazy macro trend and
this tailwind
that digitized money in terms of how can
one consumer plays another consumer so
that's one example but i think the
overarching
uh thing for me is uh fintech makes a
difference
difference and and it gets better and
better because fintech becomes
or consumers and businesses are now
trusting more technology companies
to handle many of the financial services
that were usually
served by the traditional financial
institutes like banks
issuing banks etc so i think it's a very
exciting time from a business standpoint
and also just in terms of
impact overall so i have to ask you a
little bit of a personal question
matan you're in paypal and you're
leading this
initiative globally an initiative that i
use honestly almost on a day-to-day
basis
and people from more than 200 countries
use and you wake up and you know
that you are one of the people
responsible
for over 50 billions of dollars of
transactions
annually hyper growth sounds like year
over year from 5 billion to 10 billion
and and when you wake up what is that
like are you
are you scared are you excited are you
were
like i'm trying to to imagine
what could that feel like
yeah so it's it's it's uh it's
definitely a spot on question
i think um one of the
the good things about uh if if we talked
about
soccer you know team sport it's about
the team
uh you know it's very different for a
tennis player and a soccer player with a
soccer player you have 10 other
team members on your team that you rely
on and really affect your success or
failure
um and when you're a tennis player well
you're on your own
but uh but this is a team effort and you
know the the confidence that i got
um was coming from my team and i don't
want to sound like cheesy or anything
but this is really the authentic answer
you know if i had an incredible team an
incredible team of product managers
designers engineers
legal compliance and we just felt
like you know the talent condensity uh
back then and and now with emilio makes
you feel very confident
that you can do everything and anything
um
and so it's it wasn't stressful it
wasn't really like we felt in control
and i think if i need to be maybe i'm
i'm risking
uh being over generalized generalizing
in terms of the israeli culture but
there's something about the israeli
culture
uh that is very like can do i know it's
called hutzpah
but it's like i remember maybe i'll tell
a quick personal story i remember ebay
during the gift project days we were a
seven people startup
and we partnered with ebay to enable
their group payments and ebay came to us
the cto of ebay came to us and asked us
hey
can you handle 20 million users a day
um because we were enabling this feature
never mind the details
for ebay and we were like of course we
can
uh you know and yeah we were 26 years
old and and we said
we were actually confident that we can
do it um
but you know i think maybe a different
culture or
or other people might have said i don't
know we need to check because
we only handled 500 people a day until
then uh so
from 500 to 20 million a day you know
that is that is a big jump uh luckily
for us it worked out and we
we actually were able to handle 20
million users a day
successfully um so that's this story has
a good ending
but uh but there's something about the
attitude like being very optimistic
but backing it up with you know skills
and capabilities i think is important
also
so the confidence comes from the team
but the approach to create these types
of opportunities i think it's a culture
thing um and just being very optimistic
and believing in your future
future self in a way so we're moving
from a
group payments to peer-to-peer payments
and and now
you are the ceo of of a fresh pretty
fresh i believe unicorn emilio i believe
he raised more than
250 million dollars from some of the
most incredible incredible investors
that i can think of obviously aleph
one of them and uh and bessemer and
and many many others that i'm that i'm
not listing right now
but now we're talking about small
businesses and
i have to say i go on the website and i
look through and i've heard of emilio
and in a bunch of different
scenarios but i go through and i imagine
it seems so
simple this idea and the way that you
you're making it look so simple yet
you know from everything that i've heard
in the ecosystem making payments from
small businesses is so
freaking hard and so tell me a little
bit about your understanding into
this in this market and how you're
bringing emilio now to
to simplify and really make it
accessible in every way shape or form
yeah sure and um you know i think
you're touching one of the even
key reasons for why we even started
emilio because
like like you said most of the tools
that exists today to manage
b2b payments emilio
is helping small businesses
pay their suppliers vendors contractors
there's 10 trillion dollars
of uh payouts to vendors every year by
small businesses
most of these payouts are with paper
checks or these are cake
tools and and it's really fascinating or
it was fascinating still is fascinating
for
us why why don't these businesses
shift from paper checks to a digital
payment solution i know like a venmo for
small businesses
uh because you know consumers have
definitely shifted to digital
why are small business owners lagging
behind these are the same people uh the
same business owner that is paying with
venmo
and has i don't know square as a fancy
point of sale
the same person is licking stamps and
stuffing envelopes to mail checks to
suppliers so what's going on
um and really it's related to the to to
the
notion that you've mentioned where
existing
solutions these solutions are called
accounts payable automation solutions
these are solutions that are supposed to
help a small business
manage its b2b payments its supplier
payments contractor payments
and these tools are overwhelming for
small business owners
because they're mostly designed for
finance professionals like a cfo
an accountant a finance team as they
target larger businesses where there's a
finance professional
that knows accounting and would know how
to use these
accounts payable automation solutions we
realized that there is a
an underserved market a very large
underserved market
small businesses or small business
owners they
cannot afford a cfo you know a wine shop
doesn't have a cfo
it's either the owner or a trusted
employee i know an office admin let's
say of a
of a dentist is another example that are
making like bookkeeping that are making
light
payments for the business but they are
frightened by these accountants
uh and accounting tools um and so they
require a much simpler solution
and so coming from the world of friends
and family payments of venmo and square
cash and the paypal app
we saw an opportunity to say hey let's
bring the
consumer level simplicity and consumer
level user experience
to a world that is
filled with tools that were designed by
accountants for other accounting
and so the simplicity and the clarity is
really the main differentiator
but we do address all the complicated
stuff in the background just without
requiring the user to really be an
accountant or any
have any financial expertise and by that
we are serving one of the i would say
biggest goals that fintech has which is
financial inclusion
or democratization of financial services
technology in general and with media
specifically
makes financial services more accessible
whether it's
providing tools to people that were
limited
because of their credit score or in our
case just
making things simpler so that anyone can
actually
be a financial expert without being a
financial expert so financial inclusion
making things accessible
serving an underserved market with these
financial tools
is really a big deal and simplicity is
core to all of this
right i think one of the things that
i've been you know joking with a lot of
my friends
that are also in the tech industry we've
been saying you know i don't even know
what the
in some cases what the difference
between a small business and the person
is you know
some people are operating as if they're
a small business yet so so the line is
becoming greater
and obviously this is not representative
of the whole market i'm imagining you
know
millions upon millions of small
businesses around the world that are
just breaking their head on how to get
through
all this accounting stuff and now today
especially as as payments are being made
overseas you know
in exponential amounts compared to
previously you know this simplicity i
think
it sounds like his key here did anything
surprise you along the way as you were
building melio navi obviously you've
grown very very quickly and
it's been very successful in town did
anything surprise you or your partners
as you embarked on this journey
yeah we had many surprises i think
that there's there's a reason for why
many startups
uh have like a bottom-up approach and
not a top-down approach it's very hard
um to predict an innovative move
uh or the outcome of an innovative move
you know creating budgets and
projections for the next three years
is very hard in a business that is very
innovative and
far from being predictable and so we
have tons of surprises i think you know
that
it's not going to be a unique answer i'm
sure but the biggest surprise was
was the implications of the pandemic
yeah you know last year around the end
of february
i i wasn't sure what's going to happen
with emilio like you know
when really things started escalating in
february beginning of march
you know we're serving small businesses
we heard that small businesses are
shutting down
around the world that doesn't sound like
a good thing for in general of course
but for emilio specifically it doesn't
sound
like a good thing and i was starting to
plan for the worse
um and then the opposite happened
what happened is that we didn't have
customers that unfortunately
um had to shut down uh so it definitely
we weren't completely wrong
unfortunately because uh
we did have uh quite a few businesses
that had to close shop
but what we didn't expect is that the
ones that did survive
um shifted to digital at an accelerated
space
and so the many businesses the many
small businesses
that um were actually resilient
and flexible enough to cope with the
pandemic
started shifting their business to
digital whether it's you know e-commerce
having you know shopify stripe paypal
explode
and just even there'd be to be payment
operation also shifted to digital
because it's no longer easy to pick up a
check or hand out a check
so we didn't expect
this acceleration in growth um
and that's probably the biggest surprise
to today
i love it matan are you ready for a few
fun questions
sure all right favorite subject in
middle or high school
um favorite subjects
um i i would have said math but i want
to keep my uh
personal i don't know that it's not a
great answer but i'll say
definitely sports like any everything
related to sports i just
loved um that's that's the real answer
amazing somebody that
inspires you a role model of yours
um there are there are a few
um i think what one that
um i admire which is an amazing athlete
is roger federer um the tennis player
um i think the thing i admire about him
most
regardless of his success is it's his
style
uh like a very humble um
and almost effortless style and he's
effortless because he's so talented and
so accurate
and he never sweats even um i don't know
how
but he's just accurate and that's the
for me that's the ideal
style effort like it takes a lot of
effort
to look effortless um and and federer i
guess is a great example for i'll add
the word elegance yeah because i i have
elegance
i have yet to meet an athlete that i i
watch
on tv and he gives me the composure he's
almost like a psychologist for me i
watch him and i feel
automatically better thank you so much
for coming on the show i have one last
question for you
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um uh three words
uh so um i think
um self-aware um
humble um creative self-aware humble and
creative
thank you so much best of luck with
emilio thank you for helping
millions of small businesses around the
world billions of people with
peer-to-peer payments millions of groups
through the gifts project
i think a lot of us owe a great deal to
to the incredible
innovations that you've brought on so
thank you also for taking this time to
chat with me i really appreciate it
of course thank you so much bye-bye